on that note ccsd is the fifth largest
school district in the country and with
size comes sizable problems heather
mills looks at where the district stands
heading into the new school year
it was a tumultuous often headline
grabbing school year superintendent dr
jesus jarrah fired then reinstated ccsd
school board meetings explosive
1400 calls to police about illegal drugs
on campus and violence even against
teachers but as students head into
2022-23
there's hope for a fresh start millions
of dollars allocated to safety
improvements specifically at el dorado
and clark high schools where violent
incidents on campus sparked outrage and
now change including security cameras on
school buses district wide and instant
alert systems allowing direct contact
with police in case of an emergency
students
please know that we will continue to
enforce the district
discipline code of conduct i can't
emphasize enough the safety
of our students and our staff is of the
utmost priority for me but the district
marred with teacher absences last school
year is still struggling to fill
vacancies in spite of recently hiring
more than 800 staff members 2 100
positions are currently open 1400 are
teaching jobs while the district did
increase salaries across the board
hoping to hire more and retain current
employees
burnout still tops the list it's going
to be a unique year i think last year
was very challenging and i think for a
lot of us a repeat of last year is what
we're not hoping for to help offset the
teaching gap in the classroom the nevada
department of education approved changes
for substitute teaching allowing those
with just a high school diploma to apply
for a special one-year teaching license
heather mills live local now